- I'm so excited for this show.
But welcome to the show, by
the way, welcome to our show.
- [Renata Notni] Thank you so much.
- Yeah. Have you ever met Kevin?
- No.
- No
- I mean, of... I'm a big fan of yours.
- Nice to meet you. I'm
a huge fan of yours.
- Nice to meet you.
- That was fantastic.
- Thank you so much.
I'm so happy to be here.
- I know. We are very happy to have you.
- [Renata Notni] Thank
you so much for having me.
- I love the action pack, a
little humor in there too.
But I'm gonna start with this,
because I just moved here.
Do you have a favorite eating
spot, because he gave me some?
- I've got a lot.
- Oh my God, I'm such a foodie person,
I'm always looking for food, like,
I always wanna try everything.
Probably my favorite pizza spot is here,
Rubirosa, have you tried that one?
- [Kelly Clarkson] Rubirosa?
- [Renata Notni] Have you tried that one?
- But when you say it
it sounds like the
sexiest damn pizza ever.
- [Kevin] It does sound like...
(laughing)
- [Kevin] It does.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Have you had Rubirosa?
- [Kevin] I have not
had it, I've not had it.
- No?
- But if I don't know, I got to know.
- Do you like pizza?
- Look at me and ask that question again.
(Kelly Clarkson and audience laughing)
- Oh God. Okay. You need to try that one.
- [Kevin] Okay.
- [Kelly Clarkson] I love
you so much. (laughing)
- Sorry. So you grew up
with older brothers, right?
- I do, I have one older brother.
- Were they nice ones or did
they toughen you up or...
- Right now we have the best relationship,
but when we were kids
we were kind of like-
- [Kelly Clarkson] Rough.
- [Renata Notni] Competitive.
He's two years older, so yeah.
It was a great, a fun relationship.
- I heard that you also...
I got family tattoos once
with my sister and my mother.
I heard you got family tattoos.
- Oh yeah, I do.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
My symbol for my ranch is
almost identical to that.
- [Renata Notni] You are kidding.
Yeah, there you go.
So those are my...
- I'm blown away right now.
It's like, "Is that mine?" I was-
- It's almost the same.
Are you kidding me?
- It's not the same, there's
an arrow at the top for mine.
But I was like, "What?"
- So those are our initials.
So it's Hector, the H, the L for Liliana
and R, Renata, my name.
- Yeah.
- This is incredible.
I gotta show you guys this.
(Kelly Clarkson and audience laughing)
- Oh, my God, I love it.
(Kelly Clarkson laughing and clapping)
- I got this tattoo..
- [Renata Notni] Do you have any tattoos?
- No, no, no. No, this body's clean.
- Clean. Your temple is free.
- [Kevin] Yes.
- I love it.
- Well, tell us about Zorro.
- Well, I'm so happy it's finally here.
We shot for eight months
in Canary Island in Spain.
I feel that we've seen
many versions of Zorro,
but this one is a very
modern, like, fresh,
full of action, diversity,
action, fightings.
The thing that I love the
most about this new version
is that every single
female role in the story
is very powerful and important.
And I feel that that's something
that we haven't seen before
in the other versions.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Yeah.
- So I love that.
Lolita, my character,
she's a modern woman,
she breaks the stereotypes.
She doesn't try to fit
into like society rules,
and I feel so proud of it.
- I know. It looks so
good. I'm so excited.
I love anything action-filled
with like a little humor.
and I think the-
- Yeah.
We had a lot of physical
training for that, you know.
- I heard... Wait, you
ride horses in it as well?
- Yeah.
- But you're allergic to horses.
- I am. I'm actually am.
But it was my secret
until I booked the job
because I was like-
- [Kevin] (voice drowned out)
- How did they feel when you said,
"I'm allergic to horses" all of a sudden?
- Oh God, they freaked out.
They were like, "This is not happening.
"She's always with a horse."
And I was like, "Guys, it's totally okay.
"I won't die. I can breathe."
I mean, worst-case scenario
I would look like a different person.
(audience laughing)
- Which is kind of not good.
- [Kevin] Second season.
- Like my eyes would go smaller,
like my lips would go bigger.
- [Kevin] Yeah.
- [Kelly Clarkson] Nice.
- But other than that, it's fine.
- Yeah, you just take a pill or something.
- [Renata Notni] Exactly.
- Yeah.
- [Renata Notni] It's fine.
- Oh my God, I love actors.
It's the best thing.
I never knew any before this show,
and now five seasons in,
all of you lie when
you say, about the job.
It's like, "Of course, I..." Yeah.
- Sometimes you have to do it, right?
- No, no, not sometimes. All the time.
It's every actor that comes
on this couch is like,
"Yeah, I never done that before."
But it's like, "Yeah, I
hurdled in high school."
What?
- [Renata Notni] Yeah, totally.
- Yeah, I believe it's fascinating.
But it's very bold,
because then you're just like,
"Yep, I'm gonna get on this horse
"and pretend like I rack."
- Of course. I was like,
"I'm not gonna lose this opportunity
because of my allergies."
- [Kelly Clarkson] It's very smart.
- I was like, "That's my secret."
But then I couldn't lie to the doctor.
So it was like, "Okay, I have to...
- So then the second
season, what you do is,
when you gain all the power
and the show's doing really well,
you just ride a
non-allergenic, like a poodle.
You ride a poodle.
- A poodle? A poodle?
- [Renata Notni] Exactly.
- Or like a carriage.
- In the carriage.
- That's a great idea.
That's a great idea.
- [Kevin] You guys, you've got the power.
- He's got ideas.
Well let's do a quick
commercial break, everybody.
You can see Renata's horse
allergy in action on Zorro.
It's available on Prime Video.